okay whoo
so I've got to talk about end-to-end
testing and why the game has changed so
I actually have a little story to share
as well that's kind of personal but it
means a lot to be here today so this is
my name is will and this is my wife
Diane five years ago we went to our
first J s cough in Florida in the US
this is us on Amelia Island it was a
really great time and I really
appreciated that J's cough welcomed not
just us in the community but our
significant others and our families I
think it's really important to value
that and I really appreciate that that
tradition is continued here today I had
a question at the time that I was trying
to figure out the answer to how do you
test your front-end I think we've got
some really good answers about how to
test our unit tests how to test our
functions our classes and our UI
components and isolation I think it
becomes more difficult when we try to
integrate that all these things and put
it all together a lot can go wrong on
whether it's our UI or our web api's or
our back-end or our database or even our
deployments when we put all those things
together anything could break down and
we could have all the unit tests in the
world and they won't help us in those
cases so the type of tests they try to
exercise this are called end end tests
testing things from one end all the way
to the other and back I had a lot of
really great conversations at the
conference so I move my mouse off I had
a lot of great conversations but once
took out I met this person Nicholas ball
and he talked to me for hours and little
did I know but his wife was also at the
conference Katrina and she was quickly
becoming friends with my wife while we
were hanging out talking about testing
and he talked about all the tests that
his team had written they had thousands
and thousands of unit tests
lots and lots of integration tests and
maybe a thousand or so an N test which
is quite a lot they were testing an
enterprise app which is just an app that
does way too many things and I was so
impressed with all the things he had to
say about their stack and their tools
and all the effort they put in I applied
to work at his company and a few months
later my wife and I moved out to
Colorado joined his team he and his wife
helped us unload our moving truck twice
and helped us settle in invited us over
for the holidays and became close
friends it was really awesome to have
met them at the conference and and and
now we hang out so much together today
so when I joined this team I found there
using a tool I was actually quite
familiar with selenium so selenium is a
tool written in Java that lets us test
our apps from the point of view of the
browser and it's it's a little bit old
and but it's done a lot of wonderful
things and so let's do something we
might not otherwise be able to do the
way it works is it's it's got this Java
service that just listens for commands
and you write test code in any language
actually and more often than not not
JavaScript and that language would
usually use a library to speak the
language of selenium the webdriver API
it would send those commands to the
service and the service would queue all
these commands and would try to send
them to any given browser real browsers
and so there was just a number of
different abstractions and integration
and interfaces where things could go
wrong it could be that your test code
had an issue or using the API different
and all the different API is to work
with selenium in every language and even
within JavaScript there's several
choices they're all a little bit
different those could have issues or you
could be using it incorrectly the
selenium service queuing up those
commands and sending them to the browser
drivers for each browser the browser
drivers could have bugs there are a lot
of ways where this could go off the
rails just with this architecture
so the greatest complexity of all is our
app I find that as we write modern
JavaScript apps we're doing a lot of
things now in the browser we're making
all these different API calls just when
the page loads those come back in
different timings different orders
sometimes that can cause just different
behaviors in our front-end whenever the
user interacts with the API with our UI
that makes more calls more things happen
and all these happen things happen
asynchronously
so we are rendering m''d it could finish
at any time and we don't really
necessarily know when it is at least
from our test codes point of view us as
users as humans it's very intuitive to
us but we run our test code it does
exactly what we tell to do and if it's
trying to if it clicks a button and then
it starts to read render and we try to
do the next thing
we need to be very careful about knowing
that it finished rendering or we might
get something very unexpected so the
greatest problem of all is when we take
this selenium architecture and combine
it with the complexity of our apps it's
really a recipe for just frustration and
what we'd find is we'd write a commit
and we'd run tests locally and
everything will look good we'd push it
to the build and it would fail some
tests would fail and usually in an
end-to-end test and we'd run that build
again because it was a test that we
didn't even like shouldn't have broken
and it would pass and we'd see this over
and over again and we're different
commits we just randomly failed this
different tests and we call this
flakiness and the problem might be
something with a selenium architecture
often it was a combination of that and
just the complexity of our app working
in different before with different
performance characteristics particularly
when we're on build environments they're
virtualized you know they just things
can slow down or the database anything
could make it just work a little bit
slower and one part of the stack at any
given time and something will fail
somewhere we ran into this so much we
had a bill job that would just
continuously run and check the latest
commits on master and just run all the
tests
and it would just flush out dozens and
dozens of tests that just failed a lot
even with that we just kept tripping
over this issue over and over again test
it would just fail once in a while why
do we keep doing this well these tests
we found to be extremely valuable as I
said before you could have all your
tests in the world but if everything
integrates that something breaks down
you're gonna have a really bad time and
and worst of all your users gonna have a
bad time
I mean this at the end of the day
everything we do is about building a
user experience building values so
somebody can do their job or do that
part of their life or make that one
thing easier that gives them joy makes
them happier or productive so we
invested as much as we could into making
this better I mentioned the flaky finer
but we even tried to make our tests
better in a lot of ways one example we
we took we wrote some test helpers that
would try command and if something
didn't work right it would retry it a
number of times or for a certain time
out and this is called an implicit wait
just building it into the API so you
don't have to do that manual in your
code so we also found that it helped to
mock some service once in a while
mock some services to test certain edge
cases or certain scenarios large data
things like that doing that we wrote our
some of our own service mocking
libraries to make that process easier we
invest this as much as we could into
making the developer experience of using
our tests and writing our tests better
so we keep doing it is despite how
painful it was so after a while I joined
a new team and got selenium up and
running there and that went all right
and ran some of the same issues and then
just this past fall in October I was
consulting on a project and we had run
into a serious quality problem we didn't
have a dedicated QA team and as much as
we smoked
appen every single commit there were
always cases we missed and any given
time something would stop working and
you didn't know when it happened so we
decided to write some more tests
I pulled the story to write the N
dentists and I pulled on selenium and
the first thing I had to do on my year
old MacBook was installed Java installed
the JDK aside in have that and you need
that for selenium I thought well I still
I still wish this was written in
JavaScript so the next tool I tried is
Cypress and Cypress Cypress was
something that I had actually held off
on using for a while it been closed
source up until I think May last year
and it had been in a private beta until
October and they had both a company
around some of the premium CI features
but you now that it's open-source
everything that you need is just right
up there on github if the if the team
stopped doing what they're doing the
community could pick it up and run with
it so I'd really waited to use this
until it was open freely available it
was something I've you know wanted to
use it was an MIT licensed and ready to
go so I actually used it for just maybe
two hours and I was honestly I was blown
away I was so shocked by how different
and better my developer experience was
that I wrote a proposal to a conference
after it's working for a couple hours
and Here I am so I have a few demos I'm
just gonna run through to show you how
to install it set it up what some of the
tests look like I don't wanna get too
hung up on any of the syntax or any of
the commands I just want to give you an
idea of what it's like so the first
thing you do is you just npm install it
and this actually will do a download
from one of their from their website and
pull down the right-sized app there's an
electron app involved so it's going to
pull down based on your operating system
and your CPU architecture
next you open it and the first time you
open it it kind of initializes some
things and make sure it's verified and
it's like the right thing and all and
then when it runs there's this little
pop-up saying hey to help get you
started we put some files in the file
system and you might want to take a look
at that the files are basically examples
this is just nice they there's an
example like fixture
there's example plugin custom commands'
and an example spec and the example spec
is just this kitchen sink of all the
different commands you might want and it
just gives you that quick reference
right in the repo I mean you can go to
their Docs but it's just all right there
and it just kind of gets you gives you a
little head start with what you might
want to try to do the nice thing is it's
from there it starts to get very
familiar if you've ever done BDD style
tests whether in jasmine or with mocha
and chai the syntax is going to look
very very familiar let me make this just
a little bit bigger big oh yes I worked
good all right cool all right so this is
just part of a spec file and the first
thing is like there's top-level describe
we're describing our app or some view in
our app and we can have before each's if
we're used to that and do things before
every test and most commonly we'll load
the page load a route on our app and
then from there we can have nested
describes or context in cha and mocha
and we can have our it sheds it should
do a thing it should focus on the to do
input field and then from there we can
start using the Cypress API in this case
we're doing two things we're doing site
up focus which says hey Cypress look up
what's currently focused in the window
but our P and then it tries to do an
insertion it does a [ __ ] and it says it
should have the class new to do there's
something interesting about this should
and this whole you'll see some chaining
here and there's a reason why they use
that style see this [ __ ] has this
context of I'm trying to do a [ __ ] on
something I was focused or something
that I tried to get in the Dom this vid
will keep trying until it's true
till there's a timeout this is really
nice because when we first load our page
like if we talk about asynchronous
rendering the first thing this focus
might just be the window or the document
that thing hasn't rendered that has that
class it's going to keep retrying until
it gets that until it passes and this
this permeates all their api's and
having that context and doing things
just a little bit more intelligently by
Nature I'll show you one other example
this is an example that is quite common
where you try to just get something
based on a selector it's using jQuery
under the hood so anything that anything
that's really valid selector works and
you can even do things similar to in
jQuery with Dom traversals to like get
siblings or next or parent etc and then
we just type in a little thing we want
to do and another thing I'll point out
is there's instead of having to memorize
those key codes like what key code do I
need to put in to automate Enter key or
an escape key they just use like enter
with curly braces just nice and
convenient that way so from here I want
to show you what running the test looks
like and what debugging the test looks
like all that other stuff
it's relatively similar to selenium in
terms of like we're just running tests
and using some API this were I think it
starts to take off so the first thing is
you can run a headless Lee by default it
runs headless Lee like on CI or for just
running tests locally before on a
pre-commit hook there's some nice
results there telling you everything
that passed and there's also recording
by default so you can you could actually
replay the recording of your app in and
all the tests if you want here's where
here's where it start to get a bit
different there's an electron app the
first thing that happens when you load
the electrode app there's this yellow
warning that says hey can you make sure
you're running your webserver there's a
configuration you can set your base your
route if you can figure that it'll
actually check that when this a
collection app runs to make sure that
you're running your webserver I can't
tell you how many times I've forgotten
to run my local dev server when I'm
running my tests and just tells you
right away
and then from there you can also choose
which browser and just whichever version
of chrome you want right now and or
Firefox and edge and all that eventually
I get to that and then you can run your
spec so from here we get into the test
runner the test runner is pretty neat
this is this is a at this part run it
okay good so this pretty neat this is
running in a browser like a sandbox
browser environment and the test runner
is this whole like there's our tests on
the Left there's this header on the top
that has like this this information
about what tests have passed which tests
have failed how long it's been running
we can stop and replay it there's an
there's a URL preview there's a little
target icon that's actually a Dom Dom
selector playground we can click on that
and play around with selectors to find
things in our app and there's also
viewport information at the top and our
on our right is our app so this might
seem like a little thing but this just
having it right in the same window is
very convenient there's there's a very
good reason why they put this all in the
same window so that thing on the left is
where all our commands and all our tests
are kind of logged that's called the
command lock this thing is cool when we
tell when we click on anything in there
expand one of our tests we see all the
commands that are tests tried to execute
if we click on any of those commands
it'll jump to that part of the test
it'll actually go to the da it takes Dom
snapshots throughout the test and it
replays those Dom snapshots so we can
actually jump around our tests
sequentially or out of order and replay
the state of our down and see what's
going on in our app without having to
well without much effort and you'll see
there's this thing at the bottom of our
app this is before and after certain
commands have this context of before and
after I think typing is one of them so
if you go to type in something like a
new to do you hit before you can see the
to do before something got types see
what's going on debug it maybe and you
can click to the after and see after
you've done the type command this
ability to replay the Don snapshots and
walk through our tests just by clicking
on the command log is a night-and-day
difference from anything I ever
experienced with selenium the
workflow is used to was setting up a
debugger and trying to drop a breakpoint
in my test or my app code and trying to
hopefully stop at the right point
running into all kinds of things like
default timeouts and the app reloading
and test reloading and just all kinds of
wackiness that was just always
frustrating and just be able to walk
through my tests I can see exactly
what's happening and just a little side
interesting thing if you write really
good tests about your app like this you
can actually sort of document how your
app works and a new user a new person on
the team could could look at it and get
a pretty good understanding of all the
things it does and how it behaves and
what it looks like all of that so let's
talk about debugging like really
debugging so the first thing is when we
click on those things in the test Runner
we get a we any of those any of the
things we click they have some context
of there's a Dom element involved or
there's a network request if we click on
them they just get log to the console
normally I'd have to set up a breakpoint
and throw my own console logs to get
this information and it's just right
there like just at a click we can get
that and start playing with it Dom's
debugging you can inspect the state of
the Dom in any of these snapshots you
and you have that and you can rely on
that I will say it's not necessarily
replaying all of your different redux
states for example your your true app
state it's just going based on the Dom
though I have found that in reality even
with an app using react and redux I was
able to actually interact with my UI in
some cases and things were just sort of
work and there are hooks to potentially
do things like inject Redux stay and and
snapshot that stuff I haven't gotten to
that yet I'm not sure anybody has but
there there's some crazy things we can
do with this replayability JavaScript
debugging so if that that wasn't enough
for me
I found it really awesome that I only
needed to run this one app this one
browser this one app and this one
debugger to debug both my tests and my
app code this replay is just showing
hitting a breakpoint in my test code
here and there's also hitting a
breakpoint in my app code and being able
to jump between those two contacts
normally I was used to having like a
debugger hopefully anode because my
tests were maybe written in JavaScript
and and then another one in the dev
tools for my app and I'd be bouncing
around between the two and there's just
all this cognitive load that comes with
which one of my end what am i doing
where and bouncing back and forth and
window switching just all that and when
you just start to take this other way
you know this very challenging thing
that we do every day and you put it in a
single place and you just make it that
much easier it it starts to make it fun
again so there are some other nice
things so I mentioned we had to write
our own implicit waits Cyprus does that
out of the box there's a four second
timeout which is plenty you could make
it shorter if you like you can override
that there's direct access to the Dom so
in selenium everything was being
serialized to that service I mentioned
and so you're always just getting a
serialize version of Dom because
everything's running the same JavaScript
runtime you're actually dealing with a
Dom that's in your app from your test
code like you just have it's it's just
nice and there's some service mocking
libraries built in the they they just
made it easy to define a route and
define things you want to match on like
a method or parameter and you can have
it return fixture data
it's just rolled up and that's the thing
overall like it rolls up all this
tooling that we normally be cobbling
together ourselves sign-on for the
request stuff the service mocking and
and jQuery for Dom querying and
traversal mocha and chai for the BDD
syntax and our tests it takes care of
that for us so we don't have to select
them ourselves or maintain those
dependencies and and it just becomes
this one cohesive package that is well
documented on their site the other thing
I noticed about their site both in their
blog and in their in their Docs they
have lots of little tidbits like this so
this is a thing on timeouts and
performance and it talks about this
performance trade-off when you start to
extend the timeout which is like a
common trap when writing these tests
something didn't work it wasn't ready
yet so what's in the timeout well I mean
there's there's a big catch to that
especially if you do it universally and
there's things throughout their Docs
that kind of throw this out at you
like little tidbits that aren't even
specific to Cyprus these are just like
there's a book in here about how to
write good and end tests that could
apply to selenium or whatever else tool
you want to use and I just like that I
like that they're a little bit
opinionated and they just share these
things right in their Docs so we we just
have it it's just nice that they went
that far there are trade offs so I've
been talking about how awesome it is I
do want to say you know some of the
things that it lacks that it that it
can't do yet or things you need to
consider it's a new tool it's a new
technology it's a new thing to bring
into your team there's always a cost for
that I take that very carefully
it has a style that Det Cheney syntax I
actually personally don't like chaining
that much but as I said before there's a
reason for it they like to maintain that
that that context of what you're doing
so that way they can intelligently do
the thing that you're doing next like an
assertion and they're very upfront about
their trade-offs they have a whole dock
page dedicated to this and it mentions
both permanent trade offs and temporary
trade offs a permanent trade-off is it
runs in a single browser tab I have seen
apps that try to open other tabs to do
certain things you're not gonna be able
to test those things in Cypress there's
also a temporary trade-off of browser
support they didn't try to support every
browser right out of the gates they just
chose Chrome based browsers so they got
Chrome chromium Canary and electron
browser they're working on Firefox
they're just fixing issues in that right
now squashing some bugs and they're
gonna have that soon as soon as they can
and I'm sure edge and and and so forth
will be next but that's that's something
that is very very important though
covering having cross browser support is
is key in a lot of cases and I would
suggest still having some selenium tests
just for those situations that Cypress
cannot do them I find that 99% of the
value of these tests is easily covered
by Cypress making sure that we exercise
our user experience all the different
views all the different interactions
that we care about testing each workflow
once that the user wants to do ABC tests
those things
testing any given all the different UI
components at least once that's also
really important more than anything I
would say it's ambitious they basically
reinvented the wheel and anytime you do
that you're gonna introduce at a bug
your own set of challenges and I think
they not only tried to like reinvent
selenium but to add this very
comprehensive developer experience on
top of it
that is crazy I'm like if I if I'm ever
met Brian man the original author of
this years ago I would have like told
him he was crazy and said good luck
please try and please succeed but I
don't think it's possible
don't feel bad if you fail but here here
is he's what started as an experiment he
got it working and he's built a team
around it there's I think six full-time
devs on it now and and the open source
community is growing there's thirty more
contributors on top of that that have
made contributions but there's there's
going to be bugs there's going to be
issues there's gonna be there's gonna be
the trade offs I mentioned but I'm
really glad that they made it anyway so
I would definitely say that when it
comes to end and testing and our ability
to test our user experiences the game
has changed and I would encourage I
would encourage everyone to not just
think about unit test coverage but user
experience coverage and then test is
where we solve that problem and if
you're new to this or trying to get
started
do one thing write a smoke test test
that one thing your app says it does
test that main workflow do the happy
path make sure that's good
that is going to give you 90% of the
value you're going to cover your build
and your deployments and of course that
one thing that your app is supposed to
do and from there you can start to cover
more things but that is the one thing
that you could do and it may be a day I
think I had I think I had the first few
views our app tested in like an hour or
two and then ice went from there there
was there were dozens of uses a very
heavy a lot of another enterprise
but but it didn't take long to get that
going
and I like to say this
don't let your users test your app
because if you're not automating these
things that's what you're doing you can
have a QA team you could be smoke
testing this yourself in your own
browser there's no way you're gonna
catch all the things that these
automated tests can catch as quickly as
they can catch I mean to test those
things manually what's your dev cycle
you're just creating a feedback loop
that could be so much shorter and these
things can run very quickly and catch so
much more so at was law any application
that can be written in JavaScript
eventually will right I think this is a
good thing
I just a couple weeks ago I was I was
working a visual studio and I thought
wow I remember when Adam came out and I
before that I was using sublime sublime
was great like everybody loves sublime
everyone at least used to love sublime
and maybe we've forgotten about a little
bit because we've had Adam come out and
at the time it was like oh this is
written in JavaScript an editor this
this is fast this works this is crazy
and the visual studio code and I'm
thinking now I when I use Visual Studio
code or Adam I'm not just using those
editors I'm using all these extensions
and plugins there's these ecosystems of
tools that have built up around these
tools because they were in a JavaScript
because they're written in the things
that were familiar with and I look at
Cypress I still think we're very much in
the early days it's still gaining
adoption people are still catching on
people starting to write custom commands
this people are starting to write
plug-ins like we're in the early stages
of seeing that ecosystem expand and grow
and become something beyond what the
original authors intended I really want
to thank the Cypress team they did an
amazing job there they they they
definitely ran into all these problems I
described that I experienced with
selenium and said they they wanted to do
better and they have they've built
something that not only was written in
JavaScript but tried to solve the
developer experience and tried to make
that smoother and tried to make it
encouraging for us to write these tests
that aren't always easy and I think
they've done a terrific job if
you I think the docs are great but if
you need more help than what's in their
Doc's check out their get er chat I
promise you they're really nice and and
friendly I want to finish my story my
personal story this is my family and
Nicholas's family we each had a daughter
two years ago they're born a month apart
our wives are both expecting our second
this summer I really really wanted to
bring my family here but my wife is five
points pregnant and my daughter is two
years old and wants to climb over
everything I actually asked her my
wife's doctor if I should and she yelled
at me that view very bad idea I miss
them very much but I I will also say
that Nicholas and I you know still talk
for hours and he's still teaching me
things and I'm so grateful for having
met them at Jay s comma five years ago
thank you for joining me today for
wanting to hear about how to write tests
about how to do this better about what's
changed
I hope I hope I've given you some ideas
about that I hope I've given you some
ideas about what's happened in our
ecosystem and what continues to happen
with our tooling and how that continues
to advance if you want to talk to me
after this I love talking about this
stuff please come find me
or find me on Twitter at Will's lab I
really appreciate being here thank you
[Applause]